foreign
let's go out to Aubry in San Diego Aubry
what's happening
hey yo how are you I'm good you're there
yes can you hear me okay yes and so my
understanding is you sent in a note and
then you called back and asked hey the
note was about your fiance and you
called back and said hey could my fiance
be on two is that still good
yes
oh this is gonna be awesome all right
I'm gonna bring on fiancee Kyle in San
Diego Kyle are you there
hey what's up John how are you what's up
Kyle and Aubry all right so here's how
um I'll play referee here I don't fully
know what's happening but
um Aubry you give me the rundown of why
you originally called in
and then we can go from there
okay yeah so we've been um we're engaged
and we've been together for
five years what are you what's taking
you so long Kyle
oh yeah I've been in trouble for that
before yes you should be God Almighty
okay Aubry go for it
foreign
[Music]
take your breath take a breath
okay
that's just kind of the thing is I don't
really feel like I'm his one but I do
feel like he's mine and
my original question was just I just
don't know if we should get married
okay tell me about it
when you say when you say you feel like
um he's your one but you're not his are
there other women in the picture
there has been and there's only been one
major
Downfall with that like you know
sometimes mostly in the past has just
been kind of lean green and he didn't
really act on it but there was this one
major incident but that was in the past
that was okay we got over that but now
like it's still kind of like
um it happened like the lingering is
still happening it just it sucks right
now because we're engaged we're getting
older and we're getting closer to being
married and so I'm just scared of being
in a marriage where you know that's
going to continue to happen because it's
happened quite often in our past when
you say when you say lingering what do
you mean like y'all are out at a
restaurant you just stares somebody up
and down or he's got people that he
talks to or there's people on his social
media that he's always check on like
what what is the what do you mean
lingering
yeah like he's messaged like flirted you
know like flirt like want to make other
girls feel good or want to get attention
from other girls okay
Kyle what say you man
what was that John what what's like when
you hear that when you hear your fiance
of five years
like weeping
um
and she says man I love this guy he's my
one but I don't know if I can marry him
because he's always messaging other
women and talking to other women and
trying to get attention from other women
um
how does that how does that sit with you
is that true is that not true what do
you think
I mean it's unfortunately I have been
you know
emotionally Unfaithful I remember
physically done anything with anybody
like that but you know I've sent
messages and and yeah I mean uh at one
point I did go on a date
um you know that was maybe a year and a
half ago we were going through some
trouble and then I I did go on a date
and nothing happened again but it just
it did hurt her a lot and it hurt me too
and I mean we've been together for five
years and we've been engaged for one uh
well the beginning of this year and
we're set to get married in December
so the end of this year and um
I mean I
I hate that I had hurt and I'm hearing
her say it you know I've heard it before
um
and I on my end you know and I'm not
defending myself I'm not saying I didn't
do anything at the same time you know in
this relationship I've I've asked of my
future wife for certain you know efforts
in our relationship that she also
doesn't take seriously or into
consideration or or um you know
efforts like what
um
there's uh in the beginning I put a lot
of effort into her family and I know she
did too into mine but I really put a lot
of effort into getting her family and uh
you know all of us good there's just a
little bit of distance there so
you know I I have a close relationship
with my family and it's it's always like
let's check up on each other and and you
know there's a big connection with them
and sometimes I just don't feel that
from Aubry on me and so it just
that lack of um
of effort from that side especially
because my family's you know they're
important to me sometimes I feel like it
gets in the way physically I feel like
sometimes there's just no uh romance and
intimacy I mean we haven't been intimate
in a while and every time we try
you know the past that I've done to like
see
I'm sorry sorry it's on to Aubrey is um
you know it gets in the way and and she
rejects me her body just we can't get
very far because you know the past or or
more recently it was you know which is
weren't in a good place the last time we
kind of tried and and yeah I mean I feel
rejected as a man I'm like hey you know
I want to be intimate with you I want I
want to we've been together for a very
long time and you know at the same time
though I also want to do things right
and I know we had to get married
and you know I I I was making my effort
I'm making my effort trying to make
things work sometimes I really feel like
we disagree on a lot
and I mean that's kind of where I'm at
right now I'm just feeling a little
overwhelmed a little confused I mean
this is a commitment for a lifetime one
thing we talk about all the time is it's
marriage it is once and for all and I
know that that's why I I don't want to
be a hypocrite to her she calls me you
know a hypocrite which I have been but I
definitely don't want to be a hypocrite
you know we're engaged and we were
boyfriend and girlfriend
but sure sure surely I won't bring that
into a marriage I am 100 promise you you
will
the hardest thing about getting a new
car or getting a new wife or getting a
new house or get a new job
is that you go with you
and it like
do I have your permission to kind of
just be blunt be straight up is that
cool
absolutely like we're on the same team
so it's all good I have I I think
there's more to it
I would be willing to bet money
and I don't have a lot but I'd be
willing to bet money that you haven't
told her everything
because here's why
um first of all let me say this when I
say that out loud
true or false there's more to it
true and I did mention more last night I
I confessed her that I had resorted to
pornography because there was lack of
intimacy with us and and you know
unfortunately that's part of The
Temptations would creep in and yeah I I
have
um given into them in that sense
so I I talked about that with her
yesterday um even
um
I think there's even more than that
but I'm not there
I'm not in San Diego
here's what I need you to hear both of
you
when you get married it's sickness and
in health
y'all get married it's I'm done being me
and now me is now we it's us
and Kyle with all due respect man you're
eat
ing but I'll say it for both of you
Aubry and Kyle you have created a world
where neither of you can win
and both of you have chosen to blame the
other person for the decisions and
choices that you're making
and so Kyle
you didn't have to go to pornography you
didn't have to message girls on the
internet or on Instagram you didn't have
to go meet people
in person
because you had lack of intimacy
you did those things because you chose
to
that's just a decision you made
and
something about you and whatever the
state of your relationship is the safety
that emanates from you
um is not translating to Aubry so much
that the intimacy and closeness that
she's craving her body shuts her down
shuts It Off
says this guy's not safe
there's something else here
and so if I'm if you're marrying my
daughter Kyle I don't want you marrying
her just because you know I want to do I
want to do it right I don't want you
marrying her for that
I want you marrying my daughter because
you can't imagine drawing a full breath
for the next 50 years without her by
your side
and that's not doesn't sound like this
at all
so Aubry when you hear this
or let me ask you this Aubry
can I can I be straight up with you too
yes
it sounds like you're done
you just can't fathom starting over
somewhere again and you still a lot you
still love this guy because you always
will
but it sounds like you're done are you
done
absolutely not
no I I want Kyle are you done
no be honest bro like for real
are you done and you don't want I know
you love her and I know you don't ever
want to hurt her
but are you finished
I feel as I am
you feel what I didn't understand it I
feel I feel as though I am and
you am what you're you feel like you're
finished I am dying okay
have you told her that
I have okay but but I've also told her
that maybe I am wrong and you know this
this phone call it was an effort to see
if if I'm
you know absolutely out of my mind
making the wrong decision that you know
I
don't know
okay well I'm gonna applaud you for
being honest I appreciate that
Aubry I've been ball hugging all this
time with Kyle um you've heard this
you've been feeling this this I'm
assuming none of this is new
um and you say absolutely not walk me
through that
I mean I love him and I know that
marriage isn't perfect
and that's I feel like I'm kind of on
the spectrum of optimism and negativity
I'm kind of stupid optimistic and I want
things to work you know I know marriage
is through thick and thin
and so you know we do have to have bad
times and have the good times and all
that and I'm willing to work with him
and we've had this conversation over and
over again and
so let me ask you this already if if if
behavior is a language
without using words if behavior is a
language
for the past six months what has Kyle
been telling you
sometimes he and it's like sometimes
he's in it sometimes he's really in it
but
then when he gets down he gets really
down and right now it's just like
absolutely he wants to be gone he's
making that so obvious that he like he
makes me feel disgusting that
uh he I'm going to be the one that he's
marrying he he obviously doesn't want
that but he doesn't leave like he's
still here and so it does give me
optimism that you know maybe we will
work through it because we always do
so it's hard for me to tell is it over
is it not you're still here
how come you haven't just bailed Kyle
how come you haven't it's like just
called it
that's a good question I mean
um
I don't know I mean I I love Lexi I
don't want to hurt her you were writing
when you said that and I sometimes think
that
you know
this is all very
just Temptation it's just bad mentality
I'm thinking wrong but then there's the
side of me that's like hey this is a
commitment and you guys are fighting you
know quite often and it's not something
you know
it's not I don't want to be in a
marriage where we're constantly you know
fighting and it's little bickerings here
and there and we you know
we don't understand each other on some
you know important beliefs I I you know
I've asked her and she says okay I will
try to but then I don't see that effort
and I'm like even last night I asked for
Aubry the effort you were talking about
where is it and have you brought that
here and then then I'm not talking about
intimacy either I'm talking about like
in your own
hypocritically but like it's you know
personally going to church and then
maybe joining your church Community
maybe it might be healthy for us if we
do because you know this and that but
there's no effort from that uh or on
that from her side and that does hurt me
because I mean the way I Envision my
future family is a certain way and it's
you know it's just not translating or
aubry's not doesn't want that and I ask
her if that's fair if you don't want
that but then that's what I want and so
I think except I think she brought up a
good point brother and I just want to
like like again you and me are just
having a drink eating nachos and I just
want to call it out
um I'm not saying this in the
patriarchal way in the nonsense way from
the Bro literature okay I'm not I'm not
I'm not trying to bro down
but dude you've got to lead the life you
want to lead
and so if you want to be a guy whose
family goes to church every Sunday
whether you're dating somebody or not be
a guy that goes to church every Sunday
if you want to be a guy that doesn't
have a house that there's not a lot of
fights
then every single day of your life ask
the person that you're in love with how
can I love you better today
and I'm gonna do what I can to not to
not have a house with fights and if I'm
with somebody who's
wants to fight or spicy who are always
picking stuff then I'm gonna make some
choices to not be in that relationship
but but it sounds like you have this
dream but you want somebody to drag you
along into that dream and if they don't
drag you into that dream
you're just like well bro just things
are going to happen then
but you can do that I'm just gonna beg
you man don't get married
don't do that to yourself don't do that
to Aubry
and Aubry same thing
you want to have laughter and joy and
fun and you want to be married all of
that's awesome
but you've got to do the things in your
life for you that are going to bring you
closer to Joy and optimism and
excitement and fun
I think in a weird way I don't know that
you're optimistic I think you just want
something so bad that you will put
blinders on and pretend that the rest of
the world has just gone blank because
you're gonna make you're you're bound
and determined to make this thing happen
it's like the person who wakes up one
day and it's like I'm losing 50 pounds
period not I'm gonna be healthier and
I'm gonna be a good Steward of my body
I'm going to change my life but I'm
losing 50 pounds and they start off
running eight miles a day on a treadmill
and then they start not skipping meals
and then they're six months later
they're taking diet pills and they're
way down a rabbit hole because the goal
was just to
um sever this weight off my body it was
never about getting well in whole
and it feels like you're in your head
I'm getting married to that guy I'm
gonna Overlook the fact that he keeps
telling me he doesn't want to be with me
anymore I'm going to overlook the fact
that he is engaging with other women I'm
going to overlook the fact that every
time I'm around him I pick fights with
him and I drive him crazy I'm gonna
Overlook the fact that my body shuts
down every time we try to get close to
one another I'm gonna override all that
crap because I'm getting married to him
and that's a dangerous goal to have
when you start throwing away all the
other data points
here's my hope man
um
like I can't think of anything that
would bring me more joy than
y'all calling me in a few months and
being like hey come to our wedding in
San Diego that'd be awesome
and right below that and that's just
because I'm a romantic sucker right
below that
I can't think of anything that would
bring me more joy than two adults
looking at each other saying all right
we've been together five years and I
love you
and I love you too
but just because we love each other
doesn't mean we're right for each other
forever and ever amen
and as painful and as gut-wrenching and
is heartbreaking and is as dark as it's
going to be we're gonna spend some time
apart and see what that's like
either one of those paths is fine I
think the challenge is you all both have
to recognize that both of you get to
choose that path
how's that land on you
so Kyle you've heard me talk and talk
and talk and talk
um
do you have any more peace at the end of
this call it feels like you're headed
towards a more a little more Security in
what you see down the road
uh
yeah I mean that everything you said
nothing would make me happier than
either one of those either just the
right one that's fair let me say this
you know there's there's not a right or
wrong one
there's one that we're gonna choose
and for both of you marriage is this
every day of my life I wake up and I ask
myself how can I love her better and
every day I wake up and I decide I'm
gonna be great per a great person to be
married to
every day I wake up and decide I'm gonna
love her or I'm gonna love him
that's marriage it's not a feeling it's
not a dude if you don't do this then I'm
gonna do this that's not marriage
that's a transaction that's true that's
a transaction if you don't give me four
dollars I'm not giving you a burger
that's what you do at Burger King bro
like it's not marriage
right marriage is like how can I love
you today
yeah and you all are y'all are anywhere
close to that I don't I you could get
there by December but y'all are just
gonna have to make some pretty grown-up
decisions about how you'll treat one
another
and that may look like Kyle you smashing
your phone
it may look like you deleting all social
media apps
and not calling anybody and Aubry that
may look like you deciding to have
family meals at your house once a week
and become part of this thing because if
you marry Kyle his whole family comes
with him he's been pretty clear about
that you don't get Kyle without getting
the family
how's it going overwhelmed from
eventually it's just you know time and
time it's five years I'm a happy
Father's Day you know like it's fine
yeah it's five years it's five years
we're past that now five years
so here here's here's honestly like if
y'all could
um
I say be grown-ups be adults but I don't
mean that in an ugly way but I mean if
you all could almost with business like
um like a business like persona
set up a long three-hour breakfast
together
and
go out 10 years
and say we've been married we get
married in December and we will have
been married for nine and a half years
what would we want our life to look like
then
kids jobs where are we living
have we moved out of one of the most
expensive places on planet Earth or if
we decide to stay here because it's just
so beautiful
um
what do you want our life to look like
and then back it up what would we have
to do right now to make that happen and
then you'll have to ask yourselves am I
in on that
and Kyle you may have to look at her and
say I'm not in
I don't ever want to hurt you I love you
but I'm not in
and I'm gonna stop coming around
I'm going to leave the house
I'm gonna go find my own place I'm gonna
go find my own way
and Aubry you might say
I don't want a guy that is always
texting and flirting with other women on
social media and I don't want a guy that
has good goes on dates without me and I
don't want a guy that fill in the blank
fill in the blank
and I want you to have the courage and
strength to say
I love you Kyle but this is not for me
or I want you to both look at each other
across the table and say I'm in
I'm in
Kyle you're looking for some magic you
know fairy dust to come from the sky to
to give you the answer it's not going to
come and Aubry you're waiting for this
moment when all of the other things in
this picture are gonna get swept away so
it's just perfect and and happy happily
ever after it's not gonna happen you're
gonna have to be two adults who sit down
at a table and say are you in or are you
in
and if you're not all the way in then
you're all the way out
and I will love you I'll always have a
spot for you in my heart
but we're gonna have to do the do the
right thing now
thank you all so much for being brave
and for for walking me through
um I would love it if you reached out
let me know let me know
it's a coin flip guys you all choose
I'm grateful for you